[Music]
hello you're watching the press preview
a first look at the front pages as they
come into us here it's time to see
what's making the headlines with
political editor at the daily mirror
pippa creera and editor at the politico
london playbook alex wickham they'll be
joining us in a moment and will be with
us until just before midnight so let's
take a look then at some of those front
pages for you we're going to start off
with the metro goes with images of the
chaos at kabul airport today as people
clung
to the side of planes
deaf tea also leads with a picture of
the scenes at the airport as people ran
alongside that u.s air force plane
hundreds of people are on crammed jets
is the mirrors splash the headline
desperate
the race to escape kabul is also on the
front of the times which says hundreds
of britons and afghan interpreters are
still trying to flee the country
here's your daily telegraph writing
about joe biden's defiant message in his
speech tonight standing by his decision
of course to pull u.s troops from
afghanistan
the sun's headline reads joke biden and
says the u.s president was surprised at
the speed with which the taliban
advanced
the guardian says it was reported that
joe biden was anxious to avoid a
situation similar to the hurried u.s
withdrawal from saigon at the end of the
vietnam war
and the aux post telling more of that
story at the airport showing what
appears to be people scaling the wall at
hamid karzai international airport
and i'm joined tonight by the political
editor at the daily mirror peppa carrera
and editor at the politico london
playbook alex wickham great to see you
both after what has been a desperately
sad and depressing uh 24 hours well 48
hours really pippa why don't we start
with you uh front page of the guardian
chaos in karbala's thousands struggled
to flee the taliban and that image
which we've been watching all day
terrifying image repeated on most of the
front pages and and it really does feel
like that will be the defining image
doesn't it of this us withdrawal
it really does i mean we think we're
asked by president biden not to make
parallels with vietnam and that very
striking image which we all remember
about the helicopter jetting
of taking off from the u.s embassy in
saigon the last few diplomats as the
americans fled
vietnam and
and lost the war
yet it's very hard to get away from that
feeling that something similar
is happening here with afghanistan and
those images today so striking
from kabul airport i mean i watched a
video earlier like many people of a
plane taking off and was stunned by the
number of people
on the runway who'd broken through the
barricades and were on the tarmac
desperately clinging to wheels and the
sort of the chassis the underside of the
the airplane as it took off and the
first video clip i saw stopped just
before
um i think it was this one actually
showing now it wasn't clear whether it
was landing or whether it was taking off
and then somebody pointed out to me that
actually it was on its way up into the
air and subsequently this awful awful
videos emerged
of people some of those men probably
who had been clinging to the plane
falling falling down and we understand
that a couple lost their lives the chaos
that those scenes represented um
are probably replicated across the rest
of the country i mean it's very
difficult journalists to get into parts
some parts of afghanistan at the moment
but it was truly depressing and i think
all of the front pages manage to get
across that very human
fear and anxiety that is that is being
played out amongst the afghan people
about their future and what will happen
now that the taliban are in charge
yeah alex and we'll talk about uh
president biden's speech uh in a moment
but just sticking uh with that image um
today we heard from the defense
secretary ben wallace and he got very
emotional in one interview didn't he
because he said that some people like
some of those i'm sure running along the
tarmac
won't
get out they won't make it to the us or
indeed to the uk
exactly and that is the sort of
unbearable truth that britain and
america is having to face up to tonight
ben wallace the defense secretary a
former soldier himself you know feels
extreme personally about this issue and
i think that came across um in quite a
way that perhaps we wouldn't have
imagined a defense secretary
traditionally a sort of a tough guy and
and not to say ben wallace isn't a tough
guy but um you know
really you know to show that emotion
really just shows the level of
well upset but also anger i think
tonight in the british government as to
how this has developed in the last 24 48
hours i think it was always on the cards
that america very clearly wanted to
withdraw from afghanistan it wanted to
hand over somehow it didn't feel that it
needed to have a third decade of troops
in this country but it's the way that
president biden has done this tonight
that i think has upset not just people
watching these images across the world
but also america's closest allies the
the british government as i think we
will find over the coming days will it
be starting to express and ben wallace
was starting to do it this morning just
that real quite more than frustration
it's it's rage and the fury to be honest
should we be frustrated alex as well i
mean the prime minister said in the last
day or so we've known for a long time
the way things were going um but at the
start of july he said there's no
military path to victory for the taliban
so um
he he clearly didn't know how things
were going to pan out
well this is a really fascinating point
that will be argued over the next few
days i mean it's interesting to see that
the eu leaders actually a few uh back in
july urged the american government to
just do this carefully to be wary
because it was possible that the taliban
could quickly make gains so if the eu
leaders were were sort of warning the
americans and that this was a
possibility you would have thought that
the intelligence wasn't just a complete
failure it wasn't just a case of the the
us intelligence advising the president
oh it'll all be fine but clearly there
were conflicting views clearly there
were doubts and we've heard tonight from
pres from uh from the president biden
from the from the white house that
actually it was never
impossible for the taliban to take over
this was always a possibility well that
seems a very different line from what we
were hearing from president biden
literally just a few weeks ago where he
was spinning his decision as don't worry
about it everything's going to be great
no way that anything could possibly go
wrong well it really has and that's
going to come down pretty badly on the
president over the next few weeks months
and years yeah on july the 8th he said
the likelihood there's going to be the
taliban over running everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely okay people let's look at the
front of the daily telegraph then talk a
bit more about uh biden's speech this
evening because he was defiant wasn't he
in that speech he was unrepentant about
his decision and it felt to me that it
was a speech very much squarely aimed at
the american public who we know from
polls um were ready for their troops to
come home
yes and we shouldn't really be surprised
by that because where president biden
was elected on a promise to withdraw
troops from afghanistan obviously the
process was begun um in the doha talks
by um or read by in the doha talks
eventually um but it was begun by donald
trump when he was president and donald
and joe biden made clear that he would
carry on with that plan for withdrawal i
mean it would have been very tricky
politically to have gone back on that
and to have said that last minute
actually i don't agree now is not the
time to withdraw however
joe biden tonight really seemed to
present
it as a binary choice between either
total withdrawal or staying
in the numbers troops in the numbers
that they had been in afghanistan up
until this point and i think many people
would argue that actually it didn't need
to be binary choice as alex has already
said it was about how the withdrawal
took place and that could have been done
in a much more cautious measured way
um joe biden was was very uh was was
very defiant tonight i and he said he he
was he stuck squarely behind his
decision he blamed he cast the blame not
just donald trump but also
very scathingly at the afghan leadership
the fact that they had fled and left
their country and sort of posed the
question one imagines mostly to a
domestic audience um how many more of
our uh american daughters and sons do
you think it's worth sending over to
afghanistan to fight when even the
afghan fighters themselves are not
prepared to do so now you could say that
actually the two things are linked and
one of the main reasons why the afghan
army crumbled is because of the
incredible
collapse in morale that came about
because the americans had withdrawn so
quickly and they didn't have the back up
they didn't have the air power they
didn't have the cracks the crack troops
supporting them um they didn't have
you know one of the world's biggest
superpower um
having their back anymore and that it
was inevitable that this would happen i
mean the only sort of indication that
that joe biden gave of that he may have
if not got it wrong then at least not
predicted all of this was when he said
that it had admitted this taliban sweep
it happened more quickly than they did
anticipated but it's very hard to see
how
american intelligence failed so
dramatically that they didn't weren't
able to give them any heads up that that
was likely to happen yeah i mean he did
also say he did also say didn't either
the buck the buck stops with him um
sorry to interrupt him i just want to
get alex's thoughts on the front of the
sun i mean is that a fair headline do
you think joke biden
well i mean i think it's a headline that
you know
a lot of people in the in the sort of
foreign policy establishment which is
traditionally uh pretty sympathetic to
the us government would share tonight i
mean you know we've i've seen um you
know articles being written uh and
published in the last few hours from
really respected american foreign policy
think tank people like shady hammered
from the brookings institute saying that
this is biden's america first strategy
which is obviously the slogan used by
donald trump to talk about his sort of
isolationist and inward looking
policies and now we're seeing that
applied to a democrat leader the man who
was supposed to you know
show the world that quote america is
back that's what biden was telling
everyone at the g7 in cornwall uh
earlier this year well now he's been
criticized from by people who would
traditionally be sympathetic to his
world view
now as a sort of trump-like america
first style politician which is really
an extraordinary change in fortunes from
someone who you know the much of the
media was was so relieved to see
you know become president of a lot um
last year okay uh we'll just leave it
there for the moment peppa alex uh thank
you speak in a moment coming up plenty
more from the papers
[Music]
hello again pipper and alex still with
us front page of the day telegraph uh
alex homeowners face higher energy bills
uh to pay for greener gas what's this
all about
yeah so this is a
proposal from the government tonight and
as part of its so-called hydrogen
strategy for britain um which is to
basically slap a subsidy on energy bills
for homeowners in order to pay
for greener gas hydrogen gas which the
government wants to fund around 10
percent of homes going forward and the
telegraph has gone pretty critical angle
of this policy so far saying basically
it's a lot of money it's a subsidy on on
working people up and down the country
um and it only pays for 10
you know which is a pretty small niche
number of of homes energy
but this just sums up i think the
problem that the government have on on
ahead of this uh it's cop uh summit uh
over in november and it tries to sort of
come up with some sort of world leading
as they always say policy on climate
change all of these policies are gonna
be very expensive all these policies are
gonna get a lot of criticism from the
conservatives usual supporters um
whether it's in the media or even in
their own in their own party and you
know it basically they can't come up
with an idea that will that will
gain the support of the telegraph of
tory back benches just because they all
cost so much money and when you see
other countries china russia still
emitting vast amounts of carbon you know
these papers are just always going to
ask
is it is it worth it and that's the
question that the government's
struggling to answer yeah something
they're going to have to grapple with
and uh just sum this up for us in 30
seconds if you would pippa the story
about prince andrew in the metro
yes this is prince andrew allegedly
going to go for a diplomatic community
in the virginia robert sex abuse case
that he's apparently going to face in
the states um he was the uk special
representative for trade and investment
for a decade after he left the army
you'll remember
and potentially because he was working
for the uk government would qualify for
immunity it's not because he's a member
of the royal family
the suggestions are that his lawyers are
desperate for him to avoid facing a jury
in the united states because they
could potentially
side they believe with
with the alleged victim he of course
denies these claims but regardless using
something like diplomatic immunity would
look pretty bad in pr terms for the
royal family because it might look like
he's trying to escape facing the
judicial process and proving his
innocence um
yeah yeah sorry sorry's interrupt we're
we're out of time but uh you did sum
that up very nicely for us thank you
pippa and thank you alex